Revengers has one of the worst lines of  dialogue ever written has no subtext  it's a one-hating Christian saying he's  fighting Obi-Wan and the fire Planet  Hayden Christensen goes from my point of  view the Jedi are bad yeah yeah he  literally says that too and I remember  like watching it being like that is  horrendous dude yeah uh the one in  Attack of the Clones I hate sand  of course and it's grainy it gets  everywhere  so bad and then at the end dude I  remember I remember when this movie came  out of a like eighth or ninth grade for  me but in school we watched it and we're  all making fun of Darth Vader's you know  because it's like it's like it's the  moment he becomes Darth Vader yeah and  what's his big line at the end  no  and we're always like like what dude  yeah